hannah is with us Hannah's in Valdosta
Georgia hi Hannah welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave I'm so excited to
talk to you how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
so me and my husband are recently out of
college I got out of college Bobby shows
oh and send working for a year that he
actually just graduated college and is
just now starting work and we are one to
get on track with Financial Peace
University to get rid of our students it
and other loans that we have and we had
a question about your envelope system we
have a lot of bills actually all of our
bills except for our power bill are on
auto pay and we want to know how to work
envelope system with Auto pay withdrawal
I wouldn't okay I wouldn't you know I
wouldn't I don't use the envelopes for
everything I only use them for things
you leave that you spend when you're
away from home auto pay is just like
your utilities are automatically drafted
maybe your car insurance or something is
automatically drafted there's nothing
wrong with that at all it makes life
very convenient you always get the
benefit of the discount of paying on
time and everything so you know I
wouldn't mess with that but it's stuff
like going to the grocery store that's
not on auto pay right and so you need to
say alright how much are we going to
spend on groceries for the month and
before you know when you get the first
check you cash that much and put that
much cash in an envelope that says food
on it and then you buy your food with
cash at the grocery store out of the
envelope
same thing with clothing it's not on
auto pay same thing with entertainment
it's not on a hot Oh pay four years
Sharon and I bought gasoline out of an
envelope but that was so long ago that
they didn't have pay at the pump in
those days so which sounds absurd when I
say it out loud but it was that long ago
so now I you know I just say use your
debit card at the pump and make sure
you're entering it into your every
dollar budget and you're tracking it
with your every dollar budget but so
today we don't use envelopes but for a
few categories and they generally are
things that you spend when you're
away from home if you're on your
computer paying a bill you're not away
from home okay but if you're going to
the grocery store you're going to the
clothing store you're going out for
entertainment and sometimes when people
are first starting they separate their
restaurant budget from their from from
their grocery budget and have two
envelopes and of course the restaurant
budget shouldn't have anything in it if
you're getting out of debt because you
shouldn't be going out to eat but while
you're getting your debts paid off or on
beans and rice rice and beans because
intensity and all that so have you guys
been through Financial Peace University
yet no we have not started we've been
heavily debating it and watching all
your YouTube videos and trying to just
see you if it's the right thing for us
which I'm sure it is but we're about to
get started because I actually start my
new job on Monday new hospital we just
moved to where he's living or where he's
from I don't have a new job and then we
want to get on track with it well listen
I'm going to sign you up as my gift okay
okay thank you so much if I do that if I
do that both of you go to the class yes
okay great great well I'll put you on
hold Kelly I'll get you signed up and
then you find a class in your area go
through the nine weeks and it includes
the every dollar plus for a year and it
includes all the audio and video on the
full online digital experience for a
year which is got a lot of our streaming
live events and all that kind stuff
don't miss it take full advantage of the
full membership but for sure go to the
nine week class okay yes very well thank
you so much again
you're welcome our pleasure
congratulations sounds like you got a
great start on things
hold on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll get
you guys signed up